Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
Nous allons parler
des discours totalitaires,
la montée de l'intolérance
dans notre société.
Dans le brouhaha ambiant,
qu'il s'agisse
de la pensée éveillée,
ou wokisme,
des réseaux sociaux
et la vie politique,
il y a un sentiment consensuel
au sein de l'opinion publique :
la montée de l'intolérance.
Nous vivons ensemble sans s'écouter
ni s'entendre,
abreuvés que nous sommes
par cette vague
wokiste qui prône
une radicalisation des discours
et la revanche
des minorités humiliées,
bien souvent instrumentalisées
et manipulées par le complotisme
et les fake news qui inondent
les réseaux sociaux.
Il y a aussi l'infantilisation
des esprits
en retour de la perte d'influence
du discours politique
et de la déliquescence
des idéologies
de gauche et de droite.
Nous avons là une situation
extrêmement préoccupante
parce que, sous prétexte d'exhorter
des sentiments généreux
au service de la revanche
des humiliés,
des offensés, des invisibles,
se déploient des discours
à visée totalitaire.
Autrement dit,
chacun d'entre nous
risque de se retrouver assigné
à des identités
plus ou moins
abstraites et, également,
à des allégeances communautaristes
conflictuelles.
Il s'agit d'un totalitarisme soft.
Certes,
il ne s'agit ni de fascisme,
ni de stalinisme,
mais il s'agit d'un discours
qui cherche à rendre indistinct
les races, les espèces,
les gens, les discours.
Bref, avec mes invités,
nous allons chercher
à décortiquer cette intolérance.
Je vous les présente.
Rachel Khan,
vous êtes essayiste.
Jean-François Braunstein,
vous êtes philosophe
et professeur des universités.
Hubert Coudurier,
vous êtes journaliste,
directeur du Télégramme.
Et Gérard Miller,
vous êtes à la fois
un homme de médias,
mais vous êtes d'abord
psychanalyste et essayiste.
Alors,
commençons par le wokisme.
Qu'est-ce qui est à l'origine
de ce wokisme ?
Est-ce qu'on peut dire
que c'est de la lâcheté ?
Une revanche sociale ?
Une révolte ?
Un absolu égalitaire ?
Jean-François Braunstein.
-Plusieurs choses.
A l'origine, ça part
d'une révolte sociale légitime
autour des questions de races
et autour des questions de genres,
et autres.
Mais très vite,
ça s'est transformé
en une espèce
de vision globale du monde,
une nouvelle vision.
C'est pour ça que j'ai gardé
le terme "woke", parfois discuté.
C'est un réveil,
comme les réveils religieux
protestants,
et ce qui est étonnant,
c'est que ses adeptes
refusent absolument toute discussion
avec leurs adversaires,
considérés comme représentant
une autre vision du monde
incompatible.
Ce qui est étonnant,
on le voit depuis pas mal d'années
dans les universités
américaines et françaises,
il n'est plus possible d'échanger
avec des gens avec qui
nous ne sommes pas d'accord.
J'ai été frappé de voir
que deux de mes collègues
ont refusé d'inscrire en thèse
des étudiants brillants
parce qu'ils n'arriveraient pas
aux mêmes conclusions qu'eux
à la fin de leur thèse,
avec des hypothèses différentes.
Je n'avais jamais vu ça
dans ma carrière
et on voit ici...
-Carrière, vous êtes
professeur de philosophie
à la Sorbonne.
-Je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un...
Le comble
du plaisir
pour un universitaire,
c'est de diriger la thèse
de quelqu'un de brillant
et qui n'est pas d'accord
avec nous.
Mais beaucoup de mes collègues
ne veulent diriger
que des gens qui sont d'accord.
Ils ne veulent plus échanger
d'arguments.
et c'est quelque chose qui est
tout à fait extraordinaire.
De ce point de vue,
l'université a été
un petit peu en avance
sur l'intolérance généralisée
dans les médias.
C'est encore plus choquant
parce que c'était,
j'en parle au passé, l'endroit
où on pouvait échanger des arguments
tout à fait excentriques.
Je suis un grand lecteur
de Stuart Mill, qui expliquait
dans "De la liberté"
que la liberté universitaire
repose sur la possibilité
d'avoir des opinions
même excentrique.
Ce n'est plus le cas
et aujourd'hui, il y a une espèce
de chape de plomb qui s'abat
parce que les opposants sont
considérés
comme le mal, et...
-On va rentrer
dans le détail,
mais sur cette chape de plomb,
je voudrais vous faire préciser.
Selon Michel Houellebecq,
notre grand romancier,
"toute mode venue des Etats-Unis
"finit par submerger,
tôt ou tard,
"l'Europe occidentale."
Mais certains pensent,
comme l'essayiste
Helen Pluckrose,
"La ruine en revient
"aux intellectuels français",
sous-entendu Foucault, Barthes,
Lacan, etc...
A votre avis, qui a raison,
Gérard Miller ?
C'est français
ou c'est américain,
ou est-ce qu'il y a
un wokisme français ?
-Comme vous m'avez déjà invité
dans votre émission,
vous savez que je suis
un garçon extrêmement poli.
Donc j'accepte votre introduction,
que je trouve un exemple même
d'intolérance. M. Braunstein
est professeur des universités,
je le suis également,
nous n'avons pas
la même expérience
et vous me permettrez de sourire
pour commencer cette émission
que vous avez introduite
sur un ton si grave, de sourire
de la menace wokiste,
qui me semble une menace
bien faible par rapport à d'autres
que je pourrais lister.
M. Braunstein a évoqué
certains de ses collègues,
universitaires comme lui,
en les décrivant,
après que vous parliez
des totalitaires,
comme des gens
qui seraient capables
du pire. J'ai un point de vue
tout à fait différent.
-C'est pour ça
qu'on vous a invité,
Gérard Miller.
-J'ai un point de vue différent.
Je suis pas porte-parole
du mouvement woke,
mais je trouve irrésistible
de présenter le wokisme
comme un épouvantail
à ce point terrifiant.
Permettez-moi de dire
que c'est un épouvantail
pour moineaux. Je vois surtout,
je ne dis pas
qu'il n'existe pas de dérives,
qu'il n'existe pas de l'intolérance,
existe ce que vous voulez,
mais dans cette société
qui subit tant d'injustices,
notamment celle de l'extrême droite,
y compris de la droite
et du macronisme,
je trouve amusant
que l'on veuille reprendre, je cite
ceux que vous avez évoqués,
Foucault, Lacant, Deleuze,
de les prendre
comme les responsables
d'une dérive totalitaire,
des gens...
-Personne n'a dit ça,
Gérard Miller.
-J'ai pas dit ça.
-C'est les noms qu'on cite
après une introduction
sur le totalitarisme.
-La question n'est pas celle-là.
C'est de savoir,
à votre avis,
si c'est "made in America"
ou si c'est un wokisme
qui vient aussi de France,
c'est tout.
-Vous avez raison,
ce qu'on appelle le wokisme est
"made in America",
et moi qui suit un ancien militant
anti-impérialiste,
je ne porte pas les Etats-Unis,
au-delà du raisonnable,
dans mon coeur,
même si j'ai beaucoup
d'amis américains.
Ce qu'on appelle le wokisme
au sens strict,
c'est un phénomène américain,
et on a voulu englober
dans le wokisme, puisqu'on cite,
malgré tout, en arrière-plan,
Foucault ou d'autres,
toute une série d'intellectuels
qui ont contribué,
je le regrette
pour mon collègue universitaire
qui ne le voit pas,
qui ont voulu au contraire
instiller
dans l'université une variété
de recherches, d'intelligence,
de complexité.. Lire Foucault,
ça n'est en rien...
-Il n'a jamais dit ça !
-Si vous lisez mon livre,
vous verrez que j'explique
qu'il n'y a aucun rapport
entre Foucault, Derrida, Lacan,
et ces penseurs, qui sont
identitaires. Les penseurs
que vous citez, que j'ai lus,
ce sont des auteurs
plein de contradiction, d'ironie,
de subtilité.
Ce ne sont pas des penseurs
de l'identité,
mais des identités multiples.
Foucault parlait
de jeu avec les normes,
du jeu des possibles.
Moi, je pense justement,
que l'erreur serait de dire
que cette...
Ce qui est une sorte de religion
a quelque chose à voir
avec Foucault.
Quiconque a lu Foucault,
Derrida et Lacan
sait que c'est un énorme contresens.
-On les a cités, M. Braunstein.
-Oui, mais ce n'est pas moi
qui les ai cités.
-Je ne vous en voulais pas à vous.
-Je pense que mon ami Malet
voulait que l'on discute
de cette question.
Beaucoup de gens pensent
que nous sommes responsables de ça.
Pas du tout. Ce sont des auteurs
plus subtils que ce qui revient
des Etats-Unis.
-Mais vous n'avez pas répondu
sur le fond du wokisme.
Est-ce qu'il y a une notion
de lâcheté dedans ?
Est-ce qu'il y a
une notion d'éveil ?
une notion d'intolérance ?
-J'espère ne pas choquer
les participants de ce débat
en disant que je reste,
sur plusieurs plans, léniniste.
Lénine disait que souvent,
on tord la barre dans l'autre sens.
Il n'y a aucun doute
que ce qui est en jeu du côté
de ce que vous appelez le wokisme,
c'est de tordre la barre.
D'où des excès,
des foldingueries absolues.
Je suis sensible,
étant toujours contestataire,
que ce qu'il y avait
dans le wokisme,
c'était la révolte
des minorités
et toute une série
de sentiments d'injustice
que je ne peux condamner.
On a tordu la barre
dans un sens
mais ne nous empressons pas
de faire l'inverse.
-On va voir, quand même,
l'avis de Rachel Khan
et d'Hubert Coudurier.
A ce niveau du débat,
américain ou français,
le wokisme,
et qu'est-ce que ça représente ?
-Ecoutez, moi... Déjà, j'aime bien
comment vous prononcez "wokisme",
parce que tout le monde le dit
avec le W.
C'est intéressant,
vous l'avez francisé,
vous avez mis un V.
Je préfère parler
des victimocrates,
en fait, en France.
Pour avoir vécu ces questions,
évidemment, des minorités,
parce que femme, parce que...
Afro-yiddish, pour résumer,
j'ai vécu ces questions
et les batailles pour l'égalité
dans ma chair.
En fait, j'ai vécu,
finalement, l'intolérance
de l'intérieur,
et c'est ça,
mon problème
avec ces victimocrates.
Je me refuse à dire ce mot, "woke",
parce que...
Ca ne me parle pas.
Quand on dit "woke",
pas tout à fait.
Sauf si on a lu votre dictionnaire,
mais nous, Français,
on comprend pas...
-Vous, vous parlez
d'intolérance
à l'intérieur de ces minorités,
c'est ça ?
-Si vous n'avez pas
une parole officielle
sur la question...
Si vous n'avez pas le langage
de votre peau,
c'est un problème
et vous êtes un traître.
C'est ça, mon sujet,
c'est-à-dire...
Vous le vivez peut-être
de l'extérieur,
mais à l'intérieur, on est en France
avec cette liberté d'expression,
cette nécessité de dialoguer
avec tout le monde,
voilà...
C'est-à-dire que d'être
en victimocratie permanente,
ça serait dire :
"Pourquoi je n'ai parlé
"en premier ?
Pourquoi mon temps
"n'est pas décuplé
par rapport
"à vos invités ?"
-J'aurais dû.
Je vais poursuivre
avec Hubert Coudurier.
A ce niveau du débat,
il y a quand même
une précision à apporter.
Ce wokisme à l'université
dont a parlé
Jean-François Braunstein
et qu'a contesté en partie
Gérard Miller, mais qu'a retrouvé
Rachel Khan dans les minorités,
ce wokisme à l'intérieur
des réseaux,
ce wokisme au sein
des partis politiques,
et même dans certains médias,
est-ce que, pour vous,
c'est le même mouvement ?
En tant que journaliste,
en observateur
de la vie sociale
comme de la vie politique,
est-ce que vous considérez
que c'est la même déviation
du langage ?
-Vous faites bien de rappeler,
je suis journaliste, pas penseur.
Ca fait une quarantaine d'année
que je suis la vie politique
et sociétale dans ce pays,
et je vois les évolutions.
Effectivement,
on parle depuis un certain temps
d'une américanisation
de la vie politique française,
de la vie française,
avec cette limite,
c'est qu'on prend les défauts
des Etats-Unis,
mais pas forcément
les qualités
en termes d'énergie, de créativité.
Je pense qu'il y a
une révolution globale
qui passe par les médias,
par les réseaux sociaux,
et qui est une forme
de démocratisation.
Aujourd'hui, l'autorité a perdu
de son essence traditionnelle.
Tout le monde est mis
sur le même niveau.
Un ancien président disait :
"Tout le monde se sent habilité
à parler au même niveau."
Tout le monde n'est pas capable
de penser la complexité
de la même manière.
Enfin, le wokisme est devenu
en France une espèce de mot
attrape-tout
qui s'applique partout.
On parle de wokisme anti-business.
Dans ma région, par exemple...
-La Bretagne.
-En Ille-et-Vilaine,
il y a un projet d'implantation
d'une usine
qui devait créer 500 emplois.
Là-dessus, les mouvements
écologistes s'y opposent,
et ce projet,
ça fait 5 ans qu'il n'arrive pas
à être mis en oeuvre.
Et il faudra peut-être encore 5 ans
pour qu'il puisse être
appliqué.
En réalité,
vous avez beaucoup
de militants d'extrême gauche
qui ne sont pas
de cette ville de Liffré
où le projet pourrait être appliqué
qui sont à la manoeuvre
et qui s'expriment
parce qu'ils sont organisés,
parce qu'ils maîtrisent
leur communication, et en face,
vous avez des intérêts
économiques et industriels
qui sont dans une prudence
qui confine
parfois, vous avez raison,
à la lâcheté.
Cette dictature des minorités
qui s'expriment,
et qui, quelque part,
a quelque chose de démocratique,
est-ce que la majorité
est capable de s'y opposer ?
De faire prévaloir
des arguments de bon sens,
qu'il s'agisse du genre,
de l'économie, de l'écologie ?
Non. On est dans des...
Dans des... Dans un non-débat
parce que souvent,
ceux qui pourraient apporter
des éléments
de complexification
ou de bon sens
n'osent pas s'exprimer.
C'est là où, à mon avis,
il y a une forme de lâcheté.
-Je voudrais poursuivre
avec un point particulier.
Penser le wokisme
comme une nouvelle
religion,
c'est ce que vous faites,
Jean-François Braunstein.
Est-ce que c'est pas antinomique
de notre laïcité républicaine,
qui s'est construite
par émancipation à l'égard
de la Révolution ?
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
-Je pense que c'est
antinomique de l'universalisme
républicain à bien des égards.
Ce que disait Rachel Khan
était exact,
le wokisme veut nous enfermer
dans des identités communautaires
de départ.
L'obsession de la race...
Ils en viennent à regretter
qu'on parle pas assez de race
en France,
ce qui est une bonne chose.
Plus largement, ce qui fait
que je parle de religion,
c'est qu'il y a une critique
très radicale chez ces auteurs
de l'idée même de science,
de connaissance objective.
On ne peut pas sortir
du savoir de tel dominé
versus tel savoir,
et en même temps qu'il y a
un refus d'universalisme,
il y a un refus de la recherche
de la vérité objective
et ce qui est étonnant,
c'est qu'on voit
en lisant ces auteurs -
que je persiste à appeler woke,
parce qu'il y a un éveil,
ils voient un autre monde
et on ne peut pas discuter
avec eux - il y a
une critique délibérée
des Lumières,
de l'universalisme,
de l'idée d'homme abstrait,
même si je ne dis pas
que l'universalisme,
ça marche, c'est un idéal.
Il y a une critique
de l'idée d'individu,
il ne faut plus
qu'on puisse être un individu
qui se construit
des identifications multiples,
c'est ça qui est insupportable
pour vous
comme pour moi
pour diverses raisons.
On peut être plusieurs choses
à la fois,
on change d'identité
plusieurs fois dans la journée.
Il y a cette critique,
et il y a une critique
de la connaissance des Lumières,
avec un éloge du préjugé,
des savoirs indigènes, etc...
C'est pour ça
qu'il me semble
que c'est une critique
des Lumières.
Je ne critique pas ça
d'un point de vue réactionnaire,
je me moque de ces auteurs
qui retrouvent
Bonald et les grands penseurs
contre-révolutionnaires.
Je pense que c'est,
en ce sens,
une doctrine contre l'émancipation.
-Est-ce que ça trouve grâce
auprès de vous, Gérard Miller ?
Que ce wokisme est réactionnaire
parce qu'il fait retour
à la religion ?
-Vous me permettrez de dire
quand on cite Bonald ou d'autres,
on peut citer des réactionnaires
du 20e siècle,
qu'il y a des gens qui,
officiellement,
si je puis dire,
se réclament
de ces gens-là
du côté de l'extrême droite
zemmourienne et autres.
Ca m'amuse qu'on fasse
de telles correspondances.
Là où vous avez raison,
c'est qu'il faut
à chaque fois rappeler
que nous sommes
les enfants des Lumières,
que notre République est héritière
de la Révolution française,
et de ce qu'il y a eu autour
avant et après.
Mais ne voyez-vous pas
une chose simple ?
Quand on dit que c'est bien
de ne pas parler
de race.
Si possible, n'en parlons pas.
C'est exact.
Mais ce n'est pas pour ça que ceux
qui ont la peau noir
ou qui sont arabes n'auront pas
dans notre société
des difficultés
particulières,
même si on n'en parle pas.
Ce que je vois quand j'entends
Rachel, pour me tourner vers elle,
qui évoquait ce terme
de "victimolâtre",
je le trouve terrible !
Il évoque le fait qu'il y aurait
des pseudo-victimes,
que ce serait un plaisir
de se décrire
comme victime...
-Victimocrates.
Moi, je trouve que ceux qui ont
souffert à travers l'histoire,
et relativement récente,
ont en quelque sorte
un petit temps pendant lequel
ils peuvent éventuellement déconner.
Quand on voit,
puisqu'on parle des Etats-Unis,
comment les Noirs étaient
traités encore récemment...
Quand j'étais adolescent,
il y avait des Noirs
qui ne pouvaient aller dans les bus.
Quand on voit cette histoire longue,
ignoble à l'égard des Noirs,
les Noirs américains ont
un peu de temps
avant qu'on leur fasse à la leçon.
Je suis d'accord avec vous
quand vous désignez des excès,
mais j'ai connu
en mai 68,
donc bien avant le wokisme,
la naissance du MLF,
où les femmes nous disaient,
quand on entrait dans une pièce :
"Sortez, on veut parler entre nous."
C'était pas indigne.
J'ai connu des moments,
la création du Front d'action
révolutionnaire homosexuel,
on laissait les homos entre eux
parler.
Je ne sais pas comment vous dire,
vous avez raison sur le fait
que des éléments sont
insupportables,
"nous sommes
pour l'universalisme"...
-C'est étonnant,
-Laissez un petit peu les minorité
y compris être un peu excessives,
parce qu'elles ont
le droit de l'être.
-Rachel Khan,
vous vouliez répondre.
-En tant que minorité...
-Vous êtes minoritaire ?
-C'est ça, tout le jeu du...
C'est intéressant,
parce que nous sommes en France
et nous n'avons pas
la même histoire que les Etats-Unis.
Et moi, j'ai été élevée
évidemment par un père
qui a connu la décolonisation.
Je parlerai pas de ma mère
après la Shoah,
mais de ce père
qui m'a transmis le fait
que notre origine,
c'était la bibliothèque,
qu'elle nous était ouverte.
Quand Joséphine Baker arrive
en France
et qu'elle a un homme blanc
qui lui sourit,
elle se dit :
"Ce n'est pas possible,
"je n'ai jamais vécu ça
de ma vie."
Et effectivement,
je vous rejoins,
c'est le fait
que pour lutter
contre les illuminés
qui nous empêchent de parler,
parce que ma couleur
de peau m'empêche de dire
que je suis
humaniste,
que j'aime la République,
la meilleure manière de lutter,
c'est de mettre en oeuvre l'égalité
et de se battre...
-Sincèrement, Rachel Khan...
"Votre couleur de peau
empêche"...
-Oui, vous le savez.
-Mais en quoi ? Pourquoi ?
-La sortie de "Racée", c'était ça.
La sortie de mon bouquin,
c'était par rapport
à ce que je disais,
ces mots qui vous séparent.
Je refuse qu'on me désigne
en tant que femme racisée,
par exemple,
je refuse ce mot. Et là,
pourquoi je parle de victimocrates ?
Ce mot vous enferme
depuis votre naissance,
depuis votre essence,
et jusqu'à la fin de votre vie,
et vous serez racisé
et mourrez racisé.
Pour moi, c'est terrible,
c'est l'inverse de l'émancipation
et de la liberté.
La liberté de penser,
de faire des choses,
la liberté d'être, demain,
je sais pas,
un homme blanc sur scène,
la liberté d'écrire.
-Merci.
Je vais revenir
à ce côté réactionnaire.
Vous avez vu cette citation
de Roland Barthes.
Pourquoi, à votre avis,
ce retour
au bonheur de l'identité
et cette exaltation du semblable
limitée à des communautés d'esprit
ou de pratiques ?
Est-ce que vous l'acceptez ?
Gérard Miller.
-Je crois que c'est un mauvais débat
que d'opposer l'identité
et l'universel.
Puisque Rachel a parlé de son cas,
je vais prendre le mien.
Je suis enfant de juifs polonais
arrivés avant-guerre dans ce pays.
Et... un jour, j'ai découvert
dans un litre où on parlait
de mon frère et de moi,
sur la psychanalyse :
"Gérard Miller,
fils d'immigrés polonais."
De qui parle-t-il ?
Je n'avais jamais pensé être
fils d'immigrés.
Ca a l'air absurde.
J'étais tellement français,
mais en même temps, je sais
que je me suis toujours pensé
comme juif
et je n'ai jamais vu
d'opposition,
dans tous les juifs
qui m'entouraient
de cette génération-là,
de contradiction
entre le fait d'être racisé
dans l'histoire juive
et d'être
incroyablement français.
C'est désagréable de dire
à des gens qui "ont des origines"
comme on dit,
qu'elles soient géographiques,
religieuses, de leur dire :
"Choisissez."
Non, on est
d'autant plus français
qu'on sait qui on est.
-Justement,
vous êtes en train de dire
ce que je défends depuis le début,
c'est-à-dire
que vous pouvez être juif
et universaliste, ce qui n'est pas
le cas du mouvement woke.
C'est le contraire, justement,
puisque c'est une exaltation
d'une identité particulière
qui exclut de l'universalité.
-Quand on nie l'identité
de l'autre,
il a tendance à se replier
sur cette identité.
C'est parce qu'on a maltraité
un certain nombre de gens,
qu'ils soient noirs, arabes,
musulmans, juifs
à d'autres moments de l'histoire
ou aujourd'hui,
c'est pour ça
qu'il y a ce repli
que vous appelez communautaire.
Moi, je suis,
comme vous, prof,
j'avais des étudiants,
par exemple d'origine algérienne,
qui disaient "les Français".
Je hurlais,
"Vous êtes français,
ne dites pas 'les Français'."
Mais quand j'ai eu
l'occasion d'avoir une fille,
j'ai cinq enfants,
qui s'est mariée
avec un juif très religieux,
il disait : "Les Français".
Il était juif et il disait ça.
Je lui disais :
"Arrête, tu es français."
Ne sous-estimez pas le fait
que dans beaucoup de cas,
les gens ont tendance à se replier
sur leur communauté
quand ils se sentent isolés.
-Pas uniquement.
Justement, je vais poser la question
à Hubert Coudurier.
Moi, comme journaliste politique
pendant de très nombreuses années,
aujourd'hui, je m'occupe
de l'international...
Dans les années 80,
90, comme journaliste politique,
des hommes politiques
m'appelaient
dans un quotidien national
et ils me parlaient des juifs
comme de "la communauté".
Vous voyez qu'il y avait
cette spécification,
cette spécificité qui était
accordée.
Le communautarisme existe aussi
et il est même utilisé
par les politiques.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
-Je vous conseille
un très joli film
de James Gray,
puisque vous parliez des juifs,
qui raconte son enfance
dans la communauté juive ukrainienne
de New York.
Le film s'appelle "Armageddon Time".
Ca veut dire qu'en fait, à l'époque,
ils perçoivent
l'élection de Reagan
comme l'Armageddon,
un homme qui va bouleverser
la planète
et la mettre en danger.
On peut pas resituer ce débat
sans comprendre l'évolution
du monde,
sa globalisation,
les problèmes climatiques,
les angoisses
chez les jeunes.
On dit que l'écologie
devient violente,
mais pour les jeunes,
il faut qu'elle le soit
si elle veut être entendue.
Jusqu'à présent,
dans les décennies passées,
ils n'ont pas été entendus
et aucun effort n'a été fait.
Je crois qu'il faut
prendre en compte la nostalgie
du gauchisme, de l'extrême gauche,
qui voit qu'aujourd'hui,
il est en train
de perdre la main
par rapport à des illusions,
une mythologie,
voire la progression des idées
conservatrices ou d'extrême droite,
selon comment vous les appelez,
dans le monde.
Voir ce combat incertain
entre les Trump, Biden,
Bolsonaro, Lula...
Il y a quelque chose
qui se joue en ce moment
et qui suscite
beaucoup d'angoisses.
Et je pense que le mouvement
du wokisme, c'est un mouvement
dans les deux sens.
Moi, je vois
des amis de certaines communautés,
des Arabes qui, effectivement,
ont envie d'être français
mais qui,
parfois, en doutent
et se replient sur eux-mêmes.
C'est aussi une expression
de nos contradictions actuelles
à un moment donné.
-Justement,
Rachel Khan,
puisqu'on est en train
de mondialiser le débat,
est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a un lien
entre ces replis communautaires,
ces replis
identitaires,
et au niveau des Etats,
une montée du populisme,
de l'extrême droite ?
On l'a vu
avec Trump aux Etats-Unis,
on l'a vu en Israël
avec ceux qui accompagnent
Benjamin Netanyahou,
on l'a vu avec Bolsonaro
au Brésil.
Est-ce que vous voyez
une diagonale entre les deux ?
-De toute façon,
c'est la démocratie qui a mal,
qui est malade.
Tous les régimes que vous évoquez,
les situations où le populisme,
l'extrême droite arrive
au pouvoir,
c'est la démocratie
qui est entachée
et on a un gros problème
sur l'autorité et nos fondamentaux,
comme une forme de perte
de repères.
Je ne suis pas une obsédée
du wokisme,
mais ces questions-là
d'identité,
le fait de vraiment
s'auto-convaincre
et surtout de raviver,
finalement,
des plaies du passé,
parce qu'on souffre tous,
c'est quand même quelque chose
qui...
Qui...
Qui relate, en fait,
de notre perte
de repères, je crois.
Et aussi, probablement,
du fait qu'on est
dans des temps instantanés,
où la connaissance,
la création n'est plus mise
au centre.
On parle très souvent,
face au populisme,
de guerre culturelle,
en ne mettant pas
les artistes au centre,
et je pense que là,
pour le coup, les artistes
seraient très prescripteurs,
très fédérateurs
et très réparateurs
de ces questions mondiales
qui nous écorchent
dans nos humanités.
-Je vais permuter vos rôles.
Vous êtes philosophe,
M. Braunstein.
Vous êtes psychanalyste,
Gérard Miller.
Je voudrais inverser les rôles.
Faire que vous soyez psychanalyste
et vous, philosophe.
Alors...
Je voudrais savoir,
c'est quand même intéressant
que le débat, ce débat
sur le wokisme, sur les identités,
etc...
On a été amenés
à ce que les uns et les autres
évoquent
leur identité, juif, noir...
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
-C'est une catastrophe,
pour ma part. Je pense
que les identités, on les a,
mais on n'a pas besoin
de les mettre en avant.
Ce qui étonnant,
c'est qu'aux Etats-Unis,
les gens les plus critiques
de ces questions woke,
ce sont des intellectuels noirs :
Thomas Williams, Glenn Loury,
etc... John McWhorter.
Ils ne veulent pas être définis
par leur caractère de victime.
Nous sommes toutes sortes de choses,
créateurs,
linguistes dans leur cas,
philosophes, et je trouve ça
très réducteur.
Je comprends le fait
qu'effectivement,
c'est une période de mort
des idéologies
donc ça donne un sens,
effectivement.
Je ne nie pas l'enthousiasme,
la réalité de ces idées
chez les jeunes
qui s'enthousiasment pour ça
comme pour le climat,
mais je dirais que c'est un peu
par défaut, et essayer
de fabriquer des identités
dont on a réussi,
plus ou moins,
tous sur ce plateau,
à se défaire,
c'est une énorme régression.
Je trouve pas
que c'est une bonne idée.
Ca ne veut pas dire...
La lutte anti-raciste,
c'est quelque chose.
Si on s'obsède sur la race
au nom de la lutte anti-raciste,
c'est le contraire.
La lutte contre les discriminations
de genre, oui,
mais si on est obsédé
par cette question du genre
et qu'on efface la biologie, etc.,
c'est pas non plus une bonne idée.
Je pense qu'il y a
un point de départ sympathique,
logique et acceptable,
mais c'est totalement
contre-productif.
On en arrive
à nous poser la question
"As-tu dit ça,
parce que tu es juif ?
"Ou parce que tu es juif
et pas juif ?
"Tes autres grands-parents
ne le sont pas,
"donc c'est pour ça que tu es
pour la diversité." C'est absurde.
Je pense que
c'est une énorme régression.
-A vous,
Gérard Miller. Oui ?
-Ecoutez, quand vous ne pouvez pas,
par exemple,
facilement obtenir
un appartement à louer,
parce que vous êtes arabe...
Vous savez que c'est quelque chose
qui se pose tout le temps
pour les Arabes dans notre pays.
Ils ont plus de mal que vous
ou moi à trouver
un appartement.
Vous ne pouvez pas reprocher
à ceux-là,
à celui-là ou à celle-là,
de sentir qu'il y a en effet
un problème particulier
avec leur identité.
C'est comme dire à un ouvrier
en grève pour son salaire :
"Vous n'êtes pas
qu'un salarié exploité.
"Vous êtes obsédé
par votre salaire !"
Non. Il faut accepter,
même si je vois bien
quelle est votre idée de fond,
que les exploités,
ceux qui sont discriminés
d'une façon ou d'une autre...
Ce qui est terrible,
c'est les faux discriminés,
mais dans l'ensemble,
j'ai le sentiment que,
dans ce pays,
les gens qui se sentent victimes
le sont réellement.
Ils ne sont pas que ça
et c'est très important
qu'ils le sachent,
mais ne leur reprochez pas
ce qui n'est pas
de leur fait.
-Aucun jeune n'arrive
à louer d'appartement.
C'est beaucoup trop cher.
Il y a un grave problème
et aucun n'envisage
d'acheter quelque chose.
-Comme vous le remarquez,
les jeunes, majoritairement,
ont voté
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
donc c'est bien
qu'il y a une identité jeune.
-C'est une possibilité.
-Un mot
là-dessus, Rachel Khan ?
-En fait, c'est compliqué.
Alors...
Lorsqu'on énonce certaines choses
par rapport au wokisme
et par rapport
- je continue de le dire -
à cette victimocratie...
Je pense que cette victimocratie
fait mal aux réelles victimes.
Le fait de parler
du wokisme...
Souvent, on vous dit :
"Tu en parles,
"donc tu es d'extrême droite
et dans un déni de la réalité."
Non. C'est précisément
parce que je refuse
que les jeunes soient
dans des identités
carcérales,
des identités-prisons,
qui ne leur permettent pas,
après leurs études, à 25 ans,
30 ans, 40 ans,
de se révéler jusqu'à leur mort,
que je me battrai
contre ces choses qui sont...
On n'est pas
dans des régions totalitaires,
mais c'est du langage
totalitaire.
Ca ne permet pas l'émancipation.
Pour des gens qui luttent
contre les discriminations,
qui se rappellent à la mémoire
de l'esclavagisme
ou de l'esclavage...
Les esclaves voulaient avoir
un nom et un prénom.
Les esclaves voulaient
ne pas être d'accord entre eux.
Ce n'est pas parce qu'on a
la même couleur de peau
qu'on a l'obligation
d'être d'accord entre nous.
C'est vraiment raciste
de dire
que les Noirs doivent penser
tous la même chose.
C'est catastrophique.
Je me bats bec et ongles
pour la liberté de tous,
surtout contre les discriminations
et pour les jeunes, d'avoir tous
un logement.
-Hubert Coudurier, là-dessus ?
-On a connu la crise
des missiles de Cuba.
On nous parle aujourd'hui
du danger nucléaire, avec l'Ukraine.
On a connu la guerre du Vietnam,
avec cette formidable mobilisation
des jeunes dans le monde.
Aujourd'hui,
on vit dans une société
où les gens ont peur,
ou expriment un peu trop
leurs peurs,
avec une absence d'espoir
de changement
et un pouvoir politique
qui navigue au plus près.
Regardez le chef de l'Etat.
Aujourd'hui, on susurre même
qu'il serait déprimé,
- je ne le crois pas -
mais en tous cas,
qu'il cherche un cap
et qu'il est capable,
sur des sujets comme les migrations,
avec ce bateau
à Marseille,
et d'autres sujets, comme l'Algérie,
de changer de cap en permanence.
C'est pas franchement rassurant.
On paye le prix de la transparence
et de la démocratisation
du savoir,
de la massification
de l'enseignement, par rapport
à des réponses économiques
qui sont plus compliquées
et pour lesquelles
on ne pourra changer
qu'en développant l'innovation
et la technologie.
C'est ça qui, aujourd'hui,
est un problème de fond.
C'est de donner de l'espoir
à notre société.
-Tout à fait.
Mais il y a quand même...
Sur ces minorités où,
finalement,
il n'y a pas de désaccord,
mais quand même plus
que des dissonances entre vous,
il y a un point.
Prenons,
par exemple, le féminisme.
Me Too a libéré
la parole des femmes.
C'est incontestable.
Personne ne conteste ça,
mais il y a aussi
un ultraféminisme qui existe.
Sandrine Rousseau propose,
je la cite, de "flamber
"le patriarcat
avec enthousiasme".
Ces attitudes se développent
au niveau de certaines pensées
minoritaires.
Comment vous expliquez,
Rachel Khan,
que, finalement,
l'arbitraire se confond
avec la liberté
et donc que l'arbitrage
devient l'arbitraire, aujourd'hui ?
-Vous parlez
d'un cas spécifique,
parce que...
La question de l'égalité
des droits,
la question de l'égalité
des droits des femmes, notamment,
est une chose sur laquelle
il ne faut jamais rien lâcher.
Ensuite, la problématique,
c'est d'avoir une parole
qui fasse le buzz.
Je ne vais pas du tout répondre
à la question,
mais avec les réseaux sociaux,
avec les émissions retransmises
sur les réseaux sociaux,
il y a quelque chose
où la parole
n'est plus sacrée,
dans un sens où elle fait progresser
une pensée,
mais elle est plus là
- vous avez retenu cette phrase -
pour créer un buzz.
Là, pour moi,
on est plus dans une démarche
- je vois Donald Trump
qui est juste là-bas -
de trumpisation
de la politique,
plus que de parler du féminisme,
au fond.
Là, les choses s'entremêlent.
Je ne réponds pas
à votre question, mais...
-Vous dites tout de même
que c'est une trumpisation.
-Enfin, le fait d'avoir...
-Andy Warhol disait :
"Tout le monde a le droit
à un quart d'heure de notoriété
"dans sa vie."
C'est devenu une obsession.
-Il faut trouver des petites phrases
pour apparaître en politique.
On le sait très bien.
C'est le cas de l'environnement,
du féminisme ou de l'économie.
Y a toujours cette petite phrase
qui a été, effectivement,
expérimentée
via les réseaux sociaux
et Donald Trump,
où il y a ce buzz
ou ces bad buzz,
et ça ne fait pas
avancer la question
de l'égalité des droits,
à mon sens.
-Alors, en politique,
la mode est
au "ni droite, ni gauche",
et on a un développement
des extrêmes,
en tout cas,
un éventail politique
qui se développe
sur les extrémités.
Est-ce que, à votre avis,
Gérard Miller,
c'est la fin des idéologies
ou, finalement,
ça n'est qu'une mode ?
-Non, mais attendez.
La mode, aujourd'hui, si tant est
qu'on peut utiliser ce terme,
est à la droite extrême.
Y a aucun doute
qu'un mauvais vent
souffle sur notre pays.
C'est pour ça que je trouve
qu'on fait du wokisme
un épouvantail facile.
Quand vous citez Sandrine Rousseau,
par chance,
vous n'avez pas essayé
de nous faire
trop peur avec elle.
Je la trouve formidable
et utile à la démocratie,
même si, justement,
on veut combattre telle ou telle
de ses propositions.
Moi, me fait infiniment plus peur
M. Darmanin
que je trouve
dans le courant mainstream
de la droitisation de ce pays.
Ce qui est gênant...
Je sais bien
qu'on ne peut pas courir
tous les lièvres à la fois,
mais le wokisme,
avec tous ses excès,
avec tout
ce que vous voulez,
c'est mineur,
par rapport au vrai danger :
la droitisation extrême de ce pays.
-Mais vous pouvez interpeller
G.Darmanin et S.Rousseau.
-Je pourrais,
mais comme je n'ai qu'une bouche,
qu'une langue et que deux mains,
je préfère
interpeller celui
qui me semble plus dangereux.
Je veux dire que ce qui est gênant,
dans les débats sur le wokisme,
et je ne parle pas
de vous personnellement...
C'est gênant,
car on voit pourquoi
l'extrême droite s'en est emparée.
Ca ne délégitime pas le sujet.
L'extrême droite s'en est emparée,
parce que ça lui permet
de ne pas cibler
toute une série
d'autres dangers majeurs.
C'est en ce sens-là
que je trouve que
c'est un ennemi facile,
le wokisme.
-Je vois
ce que vous voulez dire,
mais quand Sandrine Rousseau dit
qu'elle préfère
les sorcières
aux constructeurs d'EPR,
que la catastrophe a commencé
avec Descartes et le rationalisme,
que, lorsque Linné et Buffon
ont classé la nature,
ils l'ont hiérarchisée
et ont pris le pouvoir
sur la nature, ça me semble
être des propositions...
C'est amusant.
J'aime les choses comme ça,
mais c'est pour le buzz.
Moi, je pense que,
effectivement,
cette histoire
des réseaux sociaux
est un vrai problème.
L'idée, c'est qu'il y ait
des groupes de followers
qui se poursuivent
les uns les autres.
Ca a des conséquences
sur la question du genre
et sur la question de Me Too.
Effectivement,
désormais, l'idée,
c'est que le jugement se fait
sous la loi de la meute
et non pas dans un tribunal,
avec des procédures contradictoires.
De ce point de vue,
il y a un auteur américain
que j'aime beaucoup :
Bret Easton Ellis.
Il résume les wokes.
Mettez ce que vous voulez derrière.
C'est se débarrasser de l'individu.
Il y a une volonté
de se débarrasser de l'individu,
de ne plus penser par soi-même.
S.Rousseau dit ce qu'elle veut.
Je suis d'accord,
même très favorable aux absurdités
dites par des universitaires,
parce que ça permet le débat,
mais reprendre ça
comme parole d'évangile,
si je puis me permettre,
ça me semble compliqué.
Une prof d'économie qui dit
"Descartes,
"c'est le rationalisme,
donc c'est le mal"...
Je dois dire que je suis un peu...
-Hubert Coudurier ?
-Rousseau, elle fait rire,
donc elle n'est pas très dangereuse.
Darmanin est ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Il a beaucoup de pouvoir.
C'est un sous-Sarkozy.
Il fait face
à des problèmes complexes
et il y a une problématique
de l'autorité.
On verra bien si,
au final, on crédite
le chef de l'Etat
et ceux qui voudront
s'en revendiquer,
pour la présidence,
d'avoir restauré
une forme d'autorité régalienne
ou pas,
mais le fond du problème,
aujourd'hui,
il est pas là.
C'est comment on gère
la société actuelle,
comment on lui donne
une cohérence,
comment on la régule.
Est-ce l'optique sociale-démocrate
traditionnelle
que semble vouloir incarner,
aujourd'hui,
le chef de l'Etat
ou est-ce que c'est un retour
à un conservatisme dur
qui n'a d'ailleurs jamais
vraiment existé en France ?
La révolution conservatrice,
on ne l'a jamais vécue.
-Je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous
pour dire que, les paroles,
- on a cité S.Rousseau -
ça n'est que du buzz.
Je ne partage pas
votre point de vue,
parce que...
Prenons ce qu'a dit
Sandrine Rousseau.
Gérald Darmanin,
avec l'"écoterrorisme".
Prenons Cyril Hanouna qui se permet
de traiter un député LFI
de "nul"
et même de "tas de merde".
Pardon
de le citer dans le langage.
Tout ça,
c'est pas que du buzz.
Non, Gérard Miller.
Ce que parler veut dire,
ça va
au-delà du buzz.
-Sur votre plateau même,
monsieur vient de dire que
Sandrine Rousseau le faisait rire,
ce qui est assez méprisant.
Vous parlez de ses "absurdités",
donc voyez que la tolérance
n'est pas non plus absolument,
sur ce plateau, la règle.
Ca ne me choque pas,
mais ce n'est pas
simplement les wokistes
qui seraient excessifs.
Je trouve que vous avez raison
de parler du buzz
des réseaux sociaux,
mais qu'est-ce que
vous venez de faire là ?
Je connais ce que raconte
Sandrine Rousseau.
Vous avez ramassé en une
ou deux formules ce qu'elle pense,
qui est quand même
plus complexe.
Nous sommes nous-mêmes,
dans nos débats, absolument...
-Mais est-ce que vous considérez
que le propos,
quand elle compare...
Elle dit qu'elle préfère
des sorcières
à des constructeurs d'EPR.
-Alors, laissez-moi...
Ca ne me choque pas une seconde.
-Est-ce que faire flamber
le patriarcat...
Est-ce que vous acceptez...
-Cette formule,
cher M. Malet...
Celles qu'on a appelées
les sorcières à travers l'histoire,
c'était les emmerdeuses,
celles qui empêchaient
de tourner en rond l'Eglise
et la médecine, plus tard,
donc il y a eu,
chez les sorcières,
un certain nombre de femmes
qui étaient des révoltées,
qui étaient des révolutionnaires
et qu'on a brûlées,
car elles cassaient les pieds
à tout le monde,
surtout aux hommes.
Qu'elle rende
hommage à ces femmes,
par rapport à ce qu'elle dénonce
sur le nucléaire,
ça me semble,
dans une formule ramassée,
assez intéressant.
Vous savez comme moi
que c'est tout à fait utile
de réhabiliter les sorcières,
dont un grand nombre étaient
des femmes formidables.
-J'ai dit plusieurs citations,
donc vous vous rendez compte
à quel point...
-Celle-ci n'était pas
si scandaleuse que ça.
-Oui, mais le discours est
en train de déraper.
C'est pas que du buzz.
-On est tombé un cran en dessous.
-Je n'ai pas dit que
c'était que du buzz,
mais ce sont des émissions
qui sont reprises
sur les réseaux sociaux,
et ça monte,
car on est dans des algorithmes,
avec des bulles algorithmiques,
qui vous autoalimentent, etc.
Il y a quand même ce fait-là
qu'on ne peut pas négliger.
Après, là où je vous rejoins,
et ce qui
me fait mal, en fait,
c'est que, d'un côté,
on est là pour lutter
pour l'égalité des droits,
contre les inégalités,
pour les minorités,
et que ce sont des méthodes
de domination.
Vous avez dit que
c'est la meute qui,
en fait, crée
cette forme de terreur,
pour empêcher...
-C'est pas que la meute.
Quand on jette de la peinture
sur des tableaux,
est-ce une manière
de défendre la liberté ?
-Ca s'est déjà fait.
-Oui, mais même
si on l'a déjà fait !
-Aux Etats-Unis, dans les années 80,
il y avait des écologistes
extrêmement violents.
Ce qui me fait de la peine,
c'est pas cette espèce de comédie
du spectacle.
C'est la désindustrialisation
du pays.
C'est le fait qu'on ait une guerre
aux portes de l'Europe.
Ce sont des problèmes...
-Ils sont importants...
-Mais on n'en parle jamais,
sauf, peut-être, ici,
mais notre sujet n'est pas là.
En même temps, tout ce qu'on dit
sur le wokisme fait un peu écran
à tous ces problèmes de fond.
-Il y a peut-être aussi
une perte des bases de la culture.
Lorsqu'on envisage de détruire
des sublimes tableaux de Monet,
Van Gogh, etc.,
car on est obsédé par l'idée
que le monde va se terminer
dans 3, 4, 5, 10 ans,
c'est quand même assez curieux.
Est-ce que nos établissements
d'enseignement secondaire, primaire,
mettent assez l'accent
sur l'histoire de l'art ?
-Puisque vous voulez mettre
la barre très haut,
intellectuellement,
mettons-la.
Les croyances,
aujourd'hui, et tout le monde
semble d'accord là-dessus,
l'emportent sur les pensées
rationnelles.
Autrement dit,
Cyril Hanouna l'emporterait
à l'applaudimètre
sur Spinoza.
Est-ce que vous y voyez un danger
pour la démocratie ?
-Voilà une phrase
à laquelle je souscris,
surtout quand
vous citez Spinoza,
parce que j'étais professeur
de philosophie,
avant d'être professeur
de psychanalyse.
Quand on dit "les croyances",
il faut étendre ça
au-delà de Cyril Hanouna
et de ceux que nous avons cités.
Il faut parler
des religions wokes,
peut-être avez-vous raison,
mais dans ce cas,
parlons des vraies religions
qu'on n'ose pas toucher,
parce qu'il y a quelques dangers,
non seulement à toucher
la religion...
L'islam, le judaïsme
ou le catholicisme.
Vous avez raison.
C'est, actuellement,
le triomphe de l'extrême droite
et le triomphe du religieux.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord.
On voit à quel point
croire est devenu
quelque chose qui remplace
le fait de penser.
-On n'est pas au Brésil, quand même.
On n'en est pas au stade
des télévangélistes brésiliens.
-On n'en est pas encore là,
mais vous avez raison
de montrer cette ligne de mire.
C'est le télévangéliste américain.
Je vois toujours avec sidération
comme nous acceptons que,
aux Etats-Unis,
on prête serment sur la Bible.
Là, vous avez vu,
pour la première fois,
une personne homosexuelle.
"Formidable, la démocratie."
La 1re chose
qu'elle fait :
"Que Dieu bénisse l'Amérique."
Nous sommes actuellement menacés
par les croyances,
y compris religieuses,
au sens strict.
De ce point de vue-là,
je suis sidéré de voir
qu'on ne peut plus
critiquer les religions
sans risquer cher.
-Donc vous consentez
que le débat porte
sur une certaine gravité.
-Bien entendu.
-Vous critiquiez, au début.
-Non. Je considère que
le wokisme n'est pas
l'ennemi principal.
Je crois aux ennemis principaux
et secondaires.
Le wokisme n'est pas
un ennemi principal.
L'ennemi principal,
c'est actuellement la droite
et l'extrême droite,
et, au sens large,
le religieux.
-On en revient à la responsabilité
des élites,
pour s'exprimer avec courage,
pour dire les choses,
pour expliquer
la complexité des choses.
La psychanalyse peut aider,
d'ailleurs, de ce point de vue-là,
ou la philosophie.
Il y a un effort de pédagogie
à faire,
qui n'est pas toujours fait.
C'est vrai
qu'avec Cyril Hanouna,
c'est le discours de la rue
qui entre dans les foyers.
Ce n'est effectivement pas
le plus pédagogue.
On peut faire beaucoup mieux
pour expliquer
des choses complexes.
-C'est quand même quelqu'un
qui est l'employé de Bolloré
et qui dit cette phrase :
"Je ne crache pas
"dans la main
de celui qui me nourrit."
Il est le chien de garde
de Bolloré.
Il faut regarder la séquence
dans la longueur.
C'est fascinant.
Ce député ne cherche pas du tout
à faire le buzz sur Bolloré.
Il donne deux exemples,
cite Bolloré.
Le chien de garde rugit,
à ce moment-là,
le mord, le traite de tous les noms,
simplement
parce que son patron a été cité.
C'est d'une indécence absolue.
-J'aimerais revenir...
-Un mot sur la démocratie,
oui ?
On arrive bientôt à la ponctuation
de cette émission.
-Evidemment qu'il y a
une hiérarchie
entre les différents dangers,
mais je reviens juste sur le langage
et le langage woke,
qui est pour moi le début
du séparatisme.
Lorsque vous commencez à dire que,
dans notre société,
vous avez des racisés
et des non-racisés,
des afrodescendants,
des...
Je sais pas quoi.
Quand vous commencez à classer
toutes les catégories de personnes,
même s'il y a ces discriminations,
contre lesquelles
il faut se battre
main dans la main,
ça a des conséquences
pour faire un
et, notamment,
pour se battre pour notre pays,
"se battre",
pour les questions économiques,
les questions
de guerre qui approche
et être en responsabilité
tous ensemble.
-Bien, écoutez,
on va conclure cette émission.
Je vais vous demander
votre point de vue.
Même si vous n'êtes pas d'accord
sur tous les sujets évoqués,
vous êtes d'accord
pour que
la démocratie reprenne le dessus,
mais alors,
on se rend compte
que cette démocratie est
contaminée par les affects,
par les ressentiments, etc.
A votre avis,
- la question est importante -
à défaut
d'enrayer cette pente,
que, moi, j'estime totalitaire,
- peut-être que
vous ne partagez pas ça -
qui est en mesure de l'enrayer
et comment
l'enrayer ?
-Moi, je ne sais pas.
En tout cas,
ce qui est vrai,
c'est qu'il y a une montée
du culte de l'émotion, du sentiment,
de l'expérience vécue,
versus la rationalité,
l'argumentation.
C'est ce qui me semble
très inquiétant.
On peut facilement manipuler
des foules sur ces questions.
De ce point de vue-là,
c'est la question de la religion.
Je suis lecteur de Comte
qui expliquait qu'il n'y a pas
de société sans religion.
Houellebecq a repris ça
pour dire
que Comte l'avait compris.
Si on est sans religion,
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui,
on est des particules élémentaires,
donc il y a une recherche
d'une religion à tout prix.
De ce point de vue-là,
je suis d'accord.
Il y a plusieurs religions
qui se font concurrence.
Je pense que
la religion woke n'est pas
la plus solide.
D'autres risquent fort
de prendre la place.
On pourrait prendre un peu de recul
et regarder
la géopolitique de ces questions.
Ce sont nos pays d'Occident,
fatigués,
en démocratie libérale,
qui se posent
ces questions.
Autour, c'est au contraire
un argument qui est utilisé
contre nous :
voir Poutine,
voir Xi Jinping,
voir les dictatures diverses.
Je ne sais pas qu'est-ce qui peut
nous aider à nous en sortir,
mais ce serait un retour
à la raison, à l'argumentation.
C'est facile à dire,
bien sûr,
mais je pense que
c'est le travail de chacun,
dans son métier,
quand on est enseignant, comme nous,
d'essayer de refaire un retour
à la raison, à la culture,
à l'histoire de notre civilisation.
-Merci,
Jean-François.
On a peu de temps.
-Il faut des vrais lieux de débat.
Vous avez parlez des médias.
Le fait que les médias
soient possédés à 90 %
par quelques milliardaires,
ça a des effets
particulièrement nocifs
pour l'organisation de débats.
Nous sommes dans cette noble maison
de l'Assemblée nationale.
Ce serait bien aussi, ici,
qu'on ne considère pas que,
quand il y a du débat,
c'est du temps perdu.
Je considère
que le 49.3 utilisé
à tour de bras,
pour éviter de prendre en compte
le débat lui-même,
c'est un mauvais exemple
donné à la société
sur la valeur de l'échange.
-Hubert Coudurier ?
-Le débat, aujourd'hui, existe
à l'Assemblée et dans les médias.
Il y a des groupes de médias
possédés par des oligarques,
mais il n'y a pas que ça.
Il y a aussi une presse de gauche
qui reste, malgré tout,
encore assez vivace.
Le problème de la France,
aujourd'hui,
c'est d'accepter que...
On parle de l'archipélisation.
Avant, on parlait de la France
de manière indifférenciée.
On découvre une France fragmentée.
Tout le monde ne pense pas pareil.
On donne la parole à tous.
C'est finalement assez sain
pour la démocratie.
C'est ce qui lui permet
sa réadaptation.
Dans le fond,
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
se passait aux Etats-Unis
dans les années 60-70.
Ca ne veut pas dire que
ça va dans le bon sens.
On est obligé
de s'éloigner un peu de l'idéal,
de l'idéal social-démocrate
de la France,
surtout si ses principaux partisans
tapent dessus en permanence
et se comportent
comme des frondeurs
qui en minent les fondements.
C'est quand même le pays
dans le monde
où il y a
la plus grande redistribution.
Il ne faudrait pas qu'on aide
à son effondrement total.
-Vigilance pour nos plus jeunes,
peut-être dès l'école primaire.
Apprendre ce qu'est
un discours populiste,
propagandaire,
qui vous empêche
de penser par vous-même,
qui empêche la nuance,
la complexité.
Dans ces réseaux sociaux,
dans ce flot d'informations,
on a peu de temps
pour se retrouver avec soi
et savoir, dans le discernement,
quoi penser.
Il faut l'apprendre aux enfants.
"Toi-même, que penses-tu,
"au-delà du reste ?"
-Merci. Ecoutez,
on va rester sur ces paroles.
Alors, je vais vous présenter
une bibliographie.
Jean-François Braunstein,
vous avez publié
"La religion woke".
Vous démontrez,
avec vos arguments philosophiques,
que le wokisme est une religion.
Vous restez là-dessus ?
-Je maintiens, oui.
La violence des réactions
prouve bien
qu'il y a quelque chose
qui n'est pas de l'ordre
de l'argumentation.
-Très bien.
Rachel Khan, vous aviez publié
"Racée".
On en avait déjà parlé.
Depuis,
vous avez publié
un autre ouvrage.
-Oui.
C'était un roman gra...
Pardon.
Un roman graphique
sur les campagnes électorales,
avec les dessins de Xavier Gorce,
qui s'appelait
"Une partie de campagne"
et qui parlait surtout,
en creux,
de l'abstention.
-Bien.
Alors, Hubert Coudurier,
j'ai pris votre livre
"Amours, ruptures et trahisons",
où vous vous intéressez
particulièrement à la vie politique,
qui a été publié chez Fayard.
Vous restez
sur cette idée que,
en politique,
il n'y a que des amours,
des ruptures et des trahisons,
c'est-à-dire que
c'est profondément affectif ?
-C'est le point de bascule
d'un président qui, dans le fond,
a évolué progressivement
de la droite vers la gauche,
qui se voulait encore fédérateur,
qui estimait qu'il ne fallait pas
trop bousculer le pays,
à un président beaucoup plus,
finalement, trumpiste,
et qui parlait parfois
à tort et à travers,
mais qui avait en même temps
des intuitions fulgurantes.
-Vous parlez de qui ?
-Nicolas Sarkozy.
Dans le fond,
la droite n'a pas encore réussi
à en trouver l'héritier.
-Gérard Miller, je...
Vous avez peut-être publié
un autre ouvrage.
Vous allez dire que je vous ramène
à Mélenchon,
mais vous restez Mélenchon.
-Je le reste, mais...
-"Mélenchon, mai oui".
-Pas seulement.
On peut annoncer que,
sur cette chaîne,
le 12 décembre,
le prochain film
que j'ai réalisé
sur Georges Marchais,
"L'homme qui avait choisi son camp",
sera diffusé
ici même, le 12 décembre,
en prime time.
-Et qu'est-ce que
vous en dites ?
-J'essaye de rappeler
ce qu'était le Parti communiste,
à une époque où
le Parti socialiste n'était rien,
et de rappeler à quel point,
dans les années 70,
ce parti a fabriqué l'élection
de François Mitterrand.
Je retrace la vie d'ouvrier,
depuis sa naissance,
de Georges Marchais.
-Avec nostalgie
ou sans nostalgie ?
-Avec nostalgie, que j'assume,
bien qu'en 68,
je me suis cogné à la fois
contre fascistes, flics
et communistes de l'époque,
mais il y a quelque chose
dans l'histoire du PC
qu'il ne faut pas oublier.
-En mettant une distance
avec Mélenchon ?
-Là, c'est...
Mélenchon n'est pas mon obsession,
donc il n'est pas du tout présent.
-Il me reste à vous remercier.
Merci d'avoir
participé à cette émission.
Je voudrais
remercier l'équipe
de LCP.
Avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais vous soumettre
cette citation.
Je vais voir si vous trouvez
de qui elle est.
"Les mouvements totalitaires
sont des organisations
"massives
d'individus atomisés et isolés."
Vous avez une idée ?
Oui, Jean-François Braunstein ?
-Arendt ?
-Arendt, exactement. Bravo.
Vous voyez,
le philosophe nous a sauvés.
-Oui.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA